today on the matt welsh show one of the
worst examples of sexual grooming of
children at a public school is exposed
we'll talk about that plus biden warns
of the coming winter of death and a
pentagon official says that murdering
innocent children is a learning
experience for the bite administration
and people continue to beat the hell out
of each other at airports which is
apparently not against the rules i guess
and an msnbc host valiantly defends the
right of black people to use racial
slurs against white people and also me
and my people fall victim to cultural
appropriation and it doesn't feel very
good i have to say we'll talk about all
of that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now a word from one of my favorite
sponsors monk box uh look they've got a
lot of great delicious meat moiq does
but uh probably my personal favorite is
their bacon if you could see and taste
this bacon from monkbox.com you would
order it right now but for now
um it's all i can tell you just i'll
have to inform you if take my word for
it that it's delicious and that's why
you've got to get moinkbox.com monk
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and wild-caught alaskan salmon directly
to your door helping family farms become
financially independent outside of big
agriculture their animals are raised
outdoors their fish swim wild in the
ocean and monk meat is free of
antibiotics hormone sugar and all the
other junk you find pre-packaged in the
meat aisle sign up at mointbox.com
show and you'll get a year of ground
beef for free
and uh and then pick what meat what
meats you want delivered with your first
box change what you what you get each
month and cancel anytime moynique was
founded by eighth generation farmers who
were also featured on shark tank and all
you gotta do is join the
movement today go to monkbox.com walsh
right now listeners to this show get
free ground beef for a year that's one
year of the best ground beef you'll ever
taste but for a limited time spelled
m-o-i-n-k-box dot com walsh that's
moinkbox.com walsh the trouble with
trying to do an episode of this show
where i discuss the worst recent example
of left-wing lunacy in the public school
system
is that the worst recent example is
always so quickly one-upped by something
even more egregious for example i had
planned to spend some time reflecting
today
on this a school in denver centennial
elementary
advertised families of color playground
night
and they were going to hold essentially
a racially segregated recess
as the struggle for equity brings us
every day closer and closer to separate
drinking fountains again in fact the
only reason there aren't already
separate drinking funds is that drinking
fountains have all been turned off
because of covet otherwise i think we'd
probably have crossed that boundary line
months ago
of course the corporate media had to do
what it could do to uh to run cover for
the bigots over at centennial elementary
and so reuters today ran a fact check
claiming that all of the outrage over
this was misguided the article says a
denver elementary school has defended
its decision to display a sign for a
playground night for families of color
after social media users accused it of
racial segregation
no well social media users did not
accuse it of racial segregation
that's like saying that i accuse water
of being wet
families of color playground night
is racial segregation by definition you
are holding an event specially designed
for certain races and not others
unless we're expanding people of color
to include everyone
which we should by the way because every
person is a person of color if my skin
had no color
yeah i know i'm pretty pale but but if i
had no color at all i would be
translucent like some kind of jellyfish
or amoeba or maybe casper the ghost
but i am neither a deep sea creature nor
an undead spirit and thus i have color
in my skin like anybody else
but i don't think the organizers of
families of color playground night had
that in mind exactly
so the fact check continues
the school said on its website
over the years we have had several
family nights with an equity theme where
families can come together to learn and
talk about diversity and inclusivity and
service
of equity
some of these families shared with us
that since the only time many of them
see one another is that drop-off and
pick-up times we host some events where
black and latin latinx la tinx families
can meet one another connect with one
another and share their experiences
about the school with one another
they continued we are honoring their
request all families are welcome to
attend all of our events and families
from a variety of backgrounds have done
so
ah so that's how reuters gets away with
pretending that this is a fact check of
a fake news story
because after the fact the school
claimed that technically anyone even the
dirty white devils
could attend the event if they wanted to
well of course they could physically
attend the event if they wanted to the
school can't legally prevent them
but the point is that they're not
welcome
the event is not for them if they're
white it's for members of i guess
superior races
who the school says these superior races
need special events so that they can
meet each other why they can't meet each
other on their own or at normal school
functions designed for everybody when i
was a kid we had uh elementary school we
had ice cream socials
where everybody could come and you can
meet anybody you want
so why they can't do that is not
explained
now that was all bad enough
but as i said it has been usurped beaten
in the contest for most deranged public
school incident this week by events at
buena vista middle school in california
the daily wire has the story says in
october a shocking report claimed that
teachers at uh at
a salinas california middle school
secretly recruited students into a
pro-lgbt club
just got disguised as a gender equality
club without their parents knowing
in the club teachers reportedly
indoctrinated the pupils into accepting
progressive teachings on sexuality and
transgender ideology even going so far
as to coach students into changing their
gender while advising them on how to
hide their new identity from their
parents
at least one couple who said they were
parents of a student claimed they were
called into buena vista middle school
where a teacher told them that their 12
year old daughter was now a boy
according to the father when they
refused to use the daughter's preferred
pronouns the teacher called the public
safety officer to the meeting
on tuesday night they were able to
address these teachers for the first
time at a local school board meeting the
unnamed mother excoriated the teachers
for allegedly changing her daughter's
name using different gender pronouns and
altering key school accounts without her
knowledge while helping the daughter
transition into a boy
now we have some of that speech
from the mother whose name actually is
jessica
by the way and let's listen to that
let these teachers come in and act as if
they have nothing wrong they've done
nothing wrong a mistake
how long of a mistake how many mistakes
are we going to take before my child
almost lost her life they didn't tell me
that my child was suicidal
you allowed these teachers to open their
classrooms teaching predatorial
information to a young child a mindful
child that doesn't even know how to
comprehend it all
how do you not know what was going on on
your own campuses
did you think that no parent would ever
come forward you will not quiet me today
i will stand here today and protect my
child along with every other child who
has not come forward yet
do you
do they have psychiatry degrees that i
was unaware of because i didn't hire
them okay i did not hire them to sit
there and nitpick my child's brain
you took away my ability to parent my
child
even before i had any knowledge
i didn't even get to show support you
asked for support i didn't get a chance
you planted seeds miss caldera and mr
rocky mr brook and you miss pagarin
your job was to educate my child in math
science english etc do your job and let
me do mine now we're so used to hearing
uh performative outrage that it can be
jarring almost to hear true righteous
outrage but that's what that sounds like
because that was no performance this was
desperation and fury from a mother who
was trying to rescue her daughter
the epoch times has a little more on
this story it says two teachers at buena
vista middle school in salinas were
recorded coaching other teachers to
conceal the nature of lgbtq clubs from
parents at a sold-out california
teachers association conference held in
palm springs california from october
29th to october 31st
so this was before so this is backing up
a little bit this is before the incident
with the daughter before this meeting
which was this week
uh so going back in october there was a
meeting of teachers where they were
where they were being coached on how
exactly to
coach the kids
the cta event was billed as the 2021
lgbtq plus issues conference beyond the
binary identity and imagining
possibilities
jessica conan who's the mother
claims that one of her daughter's
teachers then coaxed her daughter to
join a lunch hour equality club and
began affirming her daughter as
transgender near the end of sixth grade
conan's daughter told her she might be
bisexual and by the middle of seventh
grade conan was called to the school for
this meeting with her daughter a teacher
and a school principal the teacher told
conan her daughter was trans-fluid
uh jessica said i sat across the table
and i was crying i was trying to absorb
everything they kept looking at me
angrily because i kept saying she and
that it was going to take me time to
process everything
she said i was very confused i was very
upset i was blindsided completely
blindsided the teacher accused conan of
not being emotionally supportive of her
daughter who was to be called by a new
name and male pronouns would be using
the unisex restroom at school
i felt she completely coached my child
conan said
so this is the the school
informing the parents
that their child has a brand new
identity which the school has
assisted helpfully assisted the child in
informing
your child that you thought you knew is
dead
and uh now you have a son and here's his
name this is what you're going to call
him
that's what the school's doing
now
mrs conan says that she feels like her
daughter was coached and she was coached
but i think coaching is not exactly the
right word because coaching is what you
do on the sidelines of a football game
coaching happens in workplaces parents
coach their children
but when strange adults impose their
sexual ideas onto pubescent children
and attempt to coax them into a certain
sexual lifestyle
that's what we call grooming
this mother sounds utterly traumatized
because she is traumatized her daughter
is a sexual abuse victim
and she had to sit in the room with her
daughter's sexual abusers
and be lectured by them
imagine that
your child is sexually abused and then
you get called into a meeting
with your child's abusers
and they lecture you and then call the
police on you
her daughter of course is even more
traumatized as the primary victim here
and the one whose mind and life and
self-perception are at stake
so this is grooming this is sexual abuse
and it's done by degenerate perverts
many of whom get a sexual thrill out of
having these intensely sexual
conversations with children and we know
that's the case but because the public
school system as i've pointed out many
times is utterly littered with sex
predators
it's probably time we stop pretending
that the explosion of sex assault and
pedophilia in the school system is
somehow disconnected from this sort of
psychological grooming
but there's another word that um could
be used too i think
and that is abduction
so the schools here are are not only
grooming children and abusing them but
also committing a form of kidnapping
they are in a very real sense trying to
steal children away from their parents
they want to abduct the child the one
that you know
your child the one you raised and
replace him with somebody else
i mean they're literally trying to make
a new child
with a new name and everything
it's not so much the traditional form of
kidnapping as it is a kind of invasion
of the body snatchers technique
but the effect is much the same
and morally speaking the kidnappers and
abusers in the school system aren't much
different from the predator in a van
prowling the neighborhood
they deserve to be treated with the same
contempt and hostility
and we have to protect our children from
them just the same
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so uh we'll start here the pentagon
recently announced that
nobody would be held responsible for or
punished for the uh the drone strike in
afghanistan that wiped an entire afghan
family off the map
including uh i believe it was seven
children that were that were killed
and you remember this we we heard first
about a drone strike and they said that
uh this is a a brilliant um
strategic maneuver by
our military and they they were able to
take out some very dangerous terrorists
who were uh they they were on their way
in fact i think the original story if i
remember correctly was that the
terrorists were in that moment on their
way to go blow themselves up somewhere
and kill a bunch of people so um by
through this drone strike they they had
saved
the by demonstration had saved countless
lives hundreds of lives perhaps that was
the original story
and then um and then some questions
started rising about that story it seems
a little bit strange and then and
finally they said oh you know what
our bad a little bit of a screw up there
yeah we uh we we killed an entire family
then they were totally innocent they
weren't doing anything wrong
now an official from the pentagon was on
msnbc yesterday to talk about this and
especially to defend the decision by the
pentagon which was announced this week
also
that nobody is going to be punished for
this
nobody's going to be held accountable
but he says it is uh
we'll learn from it
let's listen
how does it strike you that no one is
held accountable because i know how it
strikes a lot of people around the world
that you can get away with murder and
nobody's punished for it i do understand
that we we appreciate that not
everybody's gonna
support this decision uh what i can tell
you is we looked at this thing very very
comprehensively and again we acknowledge
that there were procedural breakdowns
processes were not uh executed the way
they should have been but it doesn't
necessarily indicate that uh that an
individual or individuals have to be
held to account for that but look uh
this is more discipline inside the
pentagon at all i mean maybe there are
no charges brought up but is anyone
demoted or disciplined for what happened
then what we are going to do there's no
there's not going to be
individual discipline as a result of
this really but what we are going to do
is learn from this
and we're going to enact and improve our
procedures and our processes to try to
make sure this doesn't happen again
my god these these sociopaths
i mean this you talk about the banality
of evil
is that guy right there kirby i think
that is
you know talking about it i wouldn't
even accept
that tone
and that sort of language from somebody
if they
you know uh
bumped into my car in a parking lot and
scratched the the the bumper of my car
they said you know uh
we don't need to hold anyone accountable
for this but yeah we'll learn from it i
i promise that i'll who knows who's
responsible for this it's those
procedures and processes went awry and
uh well but this is a learning
experience
i wouldn't accept it under those
circumstances
but we're not talking about a scratched
bumper we're talking about a vehicle
that was blown up with children inside
and what we're told is that
it's nobody's fault
it's a thing that happened it's nobody's
fault and it's a learning experience
he actually said that in so many words
it's a learning experience to kill
children
that's how the by administration looks
at it
i promise we'll learn from it
we'll all be better we'll
we'll all be better off in the end after
this experience
i mean not the family that we wiped off
the face of the earth
erased an entire bloodline they're not
going to be better off because they
don't exist but you know we will be
better
this is what you get with bureaucracy
especially a bureaucracy run by
soulless empty sociopaths which really
in the end they all will be and they all
are
but uh this is what you get bureaucracy
things happen
and nobody is responsible for them
things occur
processes are followed procedures are
enacted
and no individual is responsible for
doing it
so the bureaucracy becomes like this
itself this giant organism
and you can blame the entire thing
but you cannot pinpoint one individual
within that system and blame them and
it's designed this way that's why the
bureaucracy exists
is so that nobody within it can be
blamed for anything
a bureaucracy is one giant deflection
mechanism so that nobody is responsible
for anything that happens
even when people die
especially when people die
so this is like the the much much worse
uh deadly version of the frustration you
feel you know think about think about
when you
you have a problem with your internet or
something and you have to call your
internet service provider or you gotta
call comcast or whatever and um and
finding especially if a mistake was made
somewhere along along the line
if you're suffering at the end of some
line of incompetence and a mistake was
made and you're trying to find out who
made the mistake and how we can rectify
it
it's this
total feeling of impotence and
helplessness as you're sitting there on
the phone and cycling through one person
after another and nobody knows why it
happened or what happened nobody's
responsible for it no one is is taking
responsibility everyone is offering sort
of these
generic generalized apologies but not
accepting responsibility for it and
you're just cycled through one person to
another to the next and no one can fix
the problem right
and again it's it's designed that way
um
but that's how our government works and
in this case the stakes are a lot higher
than your internet not working
really outrageous uh meanwhile staying
in the buy administration the guy at the
top the guy ostensibly supposedly at the
top of it joe biden himself he had some
good and hope good and hopeful news as
we head into the holiday let's listen to
him
it's here now and it's spreading and
it's going to increase
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death
unvaccinated for themselves their
families and the hospital they'll soon
overwhelm
yeah um a winter of uh of death a winter
of death is upon us he says
so merry christmas
um a couple things about that first of
all you know you should know that every
winter is a winter of death people die
every winter they die every season they
die every day
um death is uh
is a part of life
unfortunately
and that is that is something we have to
remind ourselves of because it seems
like the kind of thing you wouldn't it
doesn't need to be said but it does seem
as though many peop for many people they
had never thought about this fact prior
to
covet um
but let me just suggest the strategy as
we get into the holidays we get into
christmas and uh if you're worried about
covid and everything and
here's the strategy for covet okay
you live your life
and then
if you get coveted or someone in your
family gets covered then you deal with
it in the moment
okay this is this very much has to be if
you want to if you want to live a
functional if you want to be a
functional human being living a life
living your life
living any kind of life
then this is the only way to go about it
because covet is with us forever it's
never going away so
um you have to adopt a we will cross
that bridge when we come to it mentality
and you will come to the bridge
eventually but there's no reason to sit
around every day
trembling in fear
about when you're going to stumble
across this bridge it'll happen when it
happens and it will happen
it'll happen multiple times
i hate to say so it's not even like
everyone is going to have a covet
experience and then that'll be it
same with the flu you know if you got
the flu five years ago you can't say
well i had my flu you could get it again
this year you could get it 10 years from
now
you could get it and die of it
could happen probably won't but it could
so you're going to have multiple
encounters with covid throughout your
life just like you'll have multiple
encounters with uh with many unfortunate
things
um many dangerous things many of them
more dangerous and coveted
and you live your life and then when it
happens you deal with it you stay home
you know you try to
uh of course you try to isolate yourself
from other people just like you should
with any sickness
and then you get through that and then
you go back to living your life
that's how you deal with
it especially as the more we hear about
this omicron variant
which our public health officials and
the bidet administration they're
treating omicron
or uh or omnicorn as
the greatest threat we've yet faced
and uh they're talking about reinstating
lockdowns and now we need we might need
vaccine passports for domestic travel we
might have all these kinds of drastic
measures might have to be put in place
because of omnicorn well
everything we know about omnicorn is
that it's first of all about i think
it's like 70 times more infectious
than delta
and delta was far more infectious than
the original coveted strain i think
delta was twice or three times as
infectious and this is 70 times more
infectious than that
what does that mean
if the data holds up and this is all
true we have
and the sample size at this point is
pretty large so i think we could
probably trust the data
that means that
a respiratory illness that is that
infectious you are not going to avoid it
you will get it you can it cannot be
avoided the only way to maybe avoid it
for a time is just to stay locked in
your house but even that isn't going to
be a permanent solution
so you will absolutely encounter this
probably pretty soon
but here's the good news
is that it's very very mild again
according to all the data that we have
even though it's 70x you know in terms
of
of uh of
of how it spreads of transmissibility
it's much there there are far fewer
people dying of it
than died of delta so a lot more people
are getting it but a lot fewer people
are dying from it
and uh we it also seems it seems again i
have to keep i have to keep qualifying
this according to the data
okay so i'm just telling you what the
data says what scientists are saying
and according to that um
a great many of these cases probably are
uh
are there are no symptoms all or are
totally asymptomatic
so the good news is that the bad news is
that you're going to get omnicorn if you
haven't already you're definitely going
to get it definitely
good news and it's really good news is
that you might not even know when you
get it
or you might know because you have the
sniffles for a few days
pretty good chance of that
so this would seem to me like
uh the end game for covid
not the end game in that it's going to
go away because it's not ever going to
go away
but the end game for this particular
phase getting us to a new stage where
covet is something that is you know
that even the most paranoid among us
could live with
where it's just a really mild illness
for most people and uh it cycles through
in seasons and people get it and they
and they're fine and then that's
it that's what it seems to me
if this becomes the dominant strain
that's a good thing and yet
public health officials by
administration they are treating this
like
you know we got to go into defcon one
here this is this is the worst possible
thing is defcon one the worse or is it
anyway forget about that analogy they're
treating it like this is an urgent
matter
what does that tell you
does it possibly indicate
that the people in charge of the people
who have promised to shut down the virus
have
intentions that are quite the opposite
of that
maybe it indicates that all right dr oz
is running for senate in pennsylvania
for some reason even though he doesn't
live there
and he's running as
a republican
but here's what he had to say on the
issue of life and by the way if you're
running as a republican and you're going
on fox news as he did
you would think at least you'd be
prepared for the question about abortion
and the issue of when life begins
especially with everything happening at
the supreme court right now and the
texas law so this is very much at the
forefront of the national conversation
as we call it so you think you'd be
prepared for this question you would
have some kind of answer even if it's
not a good one but dr oz appears to be
not prepared at all for this question
let's listen
what is your position as both a doctor
and a senatorial candidate on when life
begins when should we draw the line when
abortion is is legal
as a doctor i appreciate the sanctity of
life and for that reason i'm strongly
pro-life with the three exceptions i've
mentioned that's how i would vote
and when does that life begin
you know again if i'm pro-life then it's
a decision that comes back to the
sanctity of when you think life does
begin and i believe it begins when
you're in the mother's womb
when you're in the mother's womb but
that that carries you all the way up to
nine months of pregnancy
no of course that life's already started
when you're in your mother's womb but
it's a rat hole to get trapped in the
different ways of talking about you we
need as a nation to make sure the
constitution is appropriately followed
and people like me and you may be in the
same camp who are pro-life have our
feelings respected and this is something
that should not be taken away from us by
judiciary legislating from the bench
yeah but that's also something that's
going to have to be legislated and that
answer is going to have to be given
specifically
this is uh
this is always frustrating because
you're almost there
i know republicans often struggle with
this you're almost there
just take it the rest of the way
i'm not even sure what you're afraid of
at this point
i mean i know there are plenty of
cowardly republicans who are afraid to
even identify as pro-life in the first
place
and try to equivocate around that
um
but
once you have decided to dive into that
pool and you're calling yourself
pro-life okay great
even even with the uh absurd compromises
oh well i'm pro-life
except for three cases the the three
cases he mentioned which those are not
in the clip but i assume the three-click
cases are rape incest life of the mother
because those are the exceptions that
you always hear
uh which which we'll leave that aside
mostly that doesn't make any sense
because if you're if you are against
abortion which means that you affirm the
sanctity of life as he says he does and
that that children have the right to
life if that's what you believe which
you must believe because you're pro-life
then it doesn't make any sense to
suspend that
even in cases where conception happens
under these um
you know tragic circumstances
but he's already gone there and then
he's asked well when does life begin and
then he says uh it begins in the womb
well yeah but where what point in the
womb
it's a really important question he
doesn't want to answer that so he's
dancing around it why
you're already in it you're in the pool
now with pro-lifers
so if you're worried about what the
left's going to say the media is going
to say it's too late for that
you know you you can't try to
triangulate and take a slightly less
pro-life position than everybody else
and hope the media treats you better
because of it they're not
this is one thing you have to realize as
far as the meeting goes and the left
goes it's it's a you're either with us
or against us mentality
and so if you're if you are not
identifying as fully pro-abortion
in all cases if that's not what you're
saying
then
you're getting lumped in with me i hate
to tell you
and they already there are they they
draw no distinction between you and me
as as a as myself as a self-proclaimed
far-right extremist
life begins at conception no exceptions
ever for anyone right
so you're already with me whether you
want to be or not in the eyes of the
people you're trying to impress
so then why equivocate
i don't want to talk about when life
begins that's that's the question that
is the question that's the starting
question
you have to be able to answer that
why not answer it
you know what the answer is it begins at
conception
that's the biologically correct answer
no other answer could makes any sense
every other answer is arbitrary and
unscientific
all right um also on the same issue here
just wanted to quickly mention this is
an article on the npr on an npr
affiliate website
and the title is men like me benefit
from safe abortion access
and
i forget who the author of this is
because i copy and pasted it here i wish
i wish i could tell you the name of the
guy who wrote this but maybe it doesn't
matter
um and uh going down a little bit the
article says men like me
have also long been the direct
beneficiaries of safe abortion access
giving women the choice not to carry
unwanted pregnancies often means we too
can delay parenthood until we are ready
since i've spent 10 of the past 11 years
as a student most of the women i've had
sex with were also students also
progressive and also not at point in
their lives when they were looking
already to have children i try to share
responsibility for birth control and if
a woman tells me she's on it i also
trust that if she still got pregnant
however though entirely her decision i
assume we would both want the same thing
in abortion in longer terms
relationships we've had explicit
discussions about this
it's the duty of both sexual partners to
be proactive about safe sex but in
reality too often this burden falls
disproportionately on women oh that's
nice so he's concerned about women too
admittedly i've often relied on my
female sexual partners to protect me
from unwanted pregnancy during my mba i
recall panicking in an uber to the train
station after hanging out with a medical
student i had met on tinder and we had
seen a few times she had a latex allergy
we didn't use our best judgment then i
got her text she had decided to take
plan b as an extra precaution i was
relieved
to my knowledge i've never gotten anyone
pregnant on an academic level i followed
the entrenched decades-long conservative
effort to undermine access to safe
abortions yet until this moment i viewed
accessible abortion as something my
partners and i could reasonably rely on
as a last resort uh and then he goes on
and on and on talking about how he
really benefits from this i actually
yeah this article provoked i guess some
mostly jeers and mockery which is what
it deserves a little bit of outrage as
well on the right but
uh i'm all about the jeers and mockery
for something like this i'm not outraged
at all in fact i i very much
appreciate this article and and i'm
happy that this guy
wrote it
um because what he's saying here is
exactly correct
this is a hundred percent true
that abortion benefits it doesn't just
benefit i think it primarily benefits
no i don't think it does primarily
benefit
weak effeminate
um limp-wristed
pathetic loser-lazy
despicable shameful men like this
they are the beneficiaries of abortion
and so i'm very happy when any of them
can stand up and say yep that's me and i
and i love abortion so that other women
can look at this guy and say like this
this is this is what abortion is for
it's not for you it's for that guy
this guy who has managed to find
multiple sexual partners somehow which
speaks to the
collapse of standards um in our culture
today which is which is a problem in and
of itself
but that's who abortion is for
certainly not for women
because that's the guy
who is going to benefit from it quote
unquote
and will suffer not at all
he pays no price
so he's got no skin in the game
um after the sexual act is complete
anyway
he suffers no he suffers now if he if he
had a conscious conscience
you know if he had a conscience if he
had any kind of moral sense at all
then he would suffer he would suffer
greatly
from the moral guilt of what he's done
but fortunately for him he is as c.s
lewis would describe him a man with no
chest he has no conscience
and and no dignity no shame
right
and
none of that no no sense of honor
and uh he sees other people especially
other women as just objects to be used
as glorified masturbatory aids
and as as essentially sex fleshy sex
robots is how he sees them
and so abortion is just all about
avoiding um
responsibility so he could continue
being irresponsible
and using women without ever having to
pay any kind of price for that
whatsoever
now the women on the other hand
um
there's there's a very steep cost that
they pay physically
there's the physical toll of abortion
which is significant
there's the physical damage that
abortion can cause
such as potentially making it so you can
never have kids again also significant
but then also th the guilt and the
trauma
is much harder for women to escape
because they're the ones going through
this
you hear you might hear from the shout
your abortion crowd oh it was great it
was fantastic you know i had an abortion
and then we went we went afterwards to
taco bell it was just like a it was a
day out you know it's just like running
errands
they talk about it like that but that's
that's that's not true
that's a rationalization
only men like this can
can can really choose to be that
flippant about it in real life
so yeah
he's the primary beneficiary that's what
abortion is all about it's all for him
um also wanted to touch on this quickly
here's a tweet from uh from adl the
anti-defamation league do we have this
here we go so adl put up this week says
as we've told fox news numerous times
casting a jewish individual as a puppet
master who manipulates national events
for malign purposes conjures up
long-standing anti-semitic tropes about
jewish power and contributes to the
normalization of anti-semitism
this needs to be removed
and then it's a cartoon where you see
george soros and he's got he's the
puppet master with the marionettes
and um and he's got the puppet strings
on a d.a
and then on on on a
attorney general and they're holding
signs to say defund the police and no
bail
and the adl saying that this is
this is anti-semitic
which we hear this a lot
from activist groups like the adl
now but here but here's the problem
though here's the difference
um
george soros
who is the target of this
cartoon
jewish people in general are not the
target
and i don't know any jewish people who
would be happy to have george soros
appointed as their representative
i mean you could you could ask i i guess
i could ask uh ben about that see how he
feels but i'm pretty sure that he
doesn't consider george soros to be his
representative george soros is just
george soros and as it happens george
soros is a puppet master who manipulates
national events for maligned purposes
that in fact is what he is and what he
does
george soros it is a fact
that he has involved himself and
injected millions of dollars into local
races to appoint uh especially district
left-wing
district attorneys
all across the country that is a fact
that is not a conspiracy theory it's not
any kind of theory at all it is a 100
fact
that george soros is putting millions of
dollars to get these left-wing da's put
in there and they're the ones who do the
bail reform and they bail out the the or
refuse to prosecute the violent
criminals who then go out and commit
heinous acts that's a fact
the idea that you're not allowed to
point it out because he happens to be
jewish is
just absurd
all right next
bloomberg has a fascinating story here
and the the headline is giant kites that
drag cargo ships across the ocean will
be trialed next year as the industry
attempts to decarbonize
so this is a great innovation they're
talking about giant kites to pull uh
boats across the ocean
and this is uh this is the new
environmentalist sort of innovation
yeah you know it's called a sailboat all
right and it's we've had this technology
since oh about i think 4000 bc so for
about 6 000 years
so the environmentalists have discovered
a technology that has existed for six
thousand years good job guys but you
know something if we're talking about
ancient
um technology ancient forms of maritime
travel
the most environmentally friendly form
of maritime travel
you know if we're being inspired by
ancient times are like the roman galley
ships
where you have slaves you know you just
put some slaves there on the on the oars
and you have them uh
[Music]
power you across the ocean
maybe we could look at that that's
enviro that's
that is eco-friendly it's a very green
form of transportation
and i also think we've got our prisons
are full of people who could be put to
better use that way
something to think about just you know
for the sake of the environment
and uh finally the wall street journal
reports on a troubling trend it says
here's the headline how a six dollar
bass pro shops hat became a fashion
trend
uh you don't need to fish to wear this
hat in fact many of its fans have never
touched a fishing pole
you can throw it on with anything they
say
so then it goes on to talk about i had
no idea this trend existed
it's how out of the loop i am but uh it
says jesse alvarado doesn't fish or hunt
and he wouldn't describe himself as an
outdoorsy person but on many mornings mr
alvarado 25 a restaurant work in los
angeles plops a bass pro shop's trucker
hat on his head the mesh-backed cap
flashes the name and open mouth fish
logo of the 49 year old outdoor retailer
which is best known for selling reels
and duck decoys to mr alvarado it's just
a good looking hat it's a simple design
he said like you can throw it on with
anything
for a variety of reasons some involve
actual fishing the hats are in demand
and then it goes this is actually a very
very long article i didn't realize this
at first
this thing's probably like 5 000 words
long just giving examples of people
wearing bass pro shops at hats and
none of them are fishing so this is what
the kids are doing now
and that's why i want to say
my culture is not your damned hat kids
this is cultural appropriation
me as an avid
bass pro shops customer
and angler as well i didn't even know
see like i am being put on the outside
of my own culture
because of this
here's the test if you can't speak for
15 minutes about your favorite soft
plastic fishing lure and if you don't
know the difference between like a texas
rig and a carolina rig then you
shouldn't be wearing that hat
if you can't even distinguish between a
crank bait and a damned spinner bait
then then then take that hat off your
head
and by the way my favorite uh form of
soft plastic is the green pumpkin trick
worm um you used to kind of do a basic
texas rig on there put a put a you know
quarter out quarter ounce weight on it
bump it around logs and weeds and stuff
like that
if it's clear weather clear water the
bite's a little slow maybe you could do
the senko green pumpkin
i like to wacky rig it as well there
but anyway
that's besides the point what was i
saying
anyway this is cultural appropriation
and that's the other problem too because
because
usually this is how i can know that
someone is in my culture that they're
one of one of mine one of my peoples if
i see you know bass pro shop hat then i
can go up to them and i can start
talking about
fishing lures and that's and we could
talk for an hour about that it's one of
the only things i can make small talk
about
but now i know that if i go up to
someone and i say oh you like
fishing huh they're just going to stare
at me blankly
this is what culture appropriation feels
like and it does not feel good
let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
if you're planning on doing some
traveling uh over the holidays then and
you haven't signed up for the get upside
app yet then please do that right now or
at least after the show go get signed up
for this app get upside means that you
can make up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time you fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store google play right now use
promo code walsh and get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cash back on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two or three hundred dollars a month in
cash back and there's no catch the cash
back gets added right to your account uh
and it's very simple like that there's
no hidden fees or anything there's no
no red tape you have to worry about you
can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands as well are
available it's as simple as that it's
easy as that so just download the free
github site app and use promo code walsh
to get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback
on your first tank that's code walsh
with the free get upside app uh by the
way if you have not yet
and you are remember the sweet baby gang
and you haven't yet gone to
delhiwire.com shop and um gotten some
kind of gear especially as we get into
the holiday season then then i don't
know what you're doing you know you're
not a true member of the gang
unless you're giving me money
that's what cults are all about so
make sure to go to the dailywire.com
shop go to uh our store we've got all
kinds of great in fact i had oh here we
go
hang on
so we got we got these great i like
these hoodies here
this one this is a good one and this is
if you want to confuse people that's
what really is all about we've got the
um
the panda hoodie with the should i exist
so you could wear that around and uh
people are very be very confused
perhaps even more confused than when
you're wearing a a you know grown man
with a beard and a diaper okay john
murray says
don't they have really good air
filtration i'm glad to hear that um they
do
can i start smoking my pipe on a plane
or matt you might like smoking your
cigars everybody enjoys that nice aroma
yeah that's i think that's probably why
i always wonder when you get on a plane
and they
they make this point of uh telling you
not to smoke
and they go in this whole speech about
don't smoke don't don't smoke in the
bathroom i always think that people
actually do when's the last time someone
actually did that they've been doing
this disclaimer for like 30 years and
it's probably been 30 years since
someone
someone went to the bathroom on a plane
and started smoking a cigarette i've
never seen that happen i've never heard
of it
um
but back in the day yeah i mean every
plane would have smelled like smoke and
you can do it too because of the air
filtration so
i'm very much in favor of going back to
a time when every indoor environment
reeked of tobacco smoke
i'm in favor of that
especially certain places like bowling
alleys i'm old enough to remember you go
into a back in the day you go into a
bowling alley and it's just like it's
like stepping into an ashtray
and it sounds unpleasant maybe it is but
that's part of the bowling alley
experience and i i long for it
seeking light says matt as a physical
therapist and one who has looked into
actual studies about how much protection
a mask provides the reason the nose is
covered is that aerosol particles from
sneezes are propelled further than cough
particles
an airplane engineer once told me that
cabin air in a passenger jet is replaced
something on the order of every two
seconds meaning that your regular
breathing in a plane would never allow
your expelled air with normal breathing
to even reach the person next to you
yeah i've tried to explain this to
people i was talking about it on twitter
yesterday that
in an airplane 30 000 feet in the air
is
really is the safest place on earth that
you can be
in pretty much every way including uh
when it comes to germs
there's not gonna be a more sanitized
environment that you'll ever find
yourself in as a regular person
every other place because they don't
have the same kind of air filtration
they're also pumping
air in from the outside the plane
which is very very clean air so
um
but you tell people this and it it
it doesn't intuitively it doesn't make
any sense to them and so especially when
that's the case people are impervious to
any kind of data or anything they don't
want to hear it
so intuitively it just seems like while
you're trapped in this tin bucket with
other people surrounded by people this
must be really dirty air and people must
be getting sick all the time it's not
true but
good luck trying to convince people that
dave says hands down the greatest daily
cancellation so great that i after
following daily wire hosts for years
will now purchase a membership
well thank you you're freeloader
finally becoming a paying member sean
says catholics are not christians you
cannot mix man-made doctrines with the
word of lord god the father
okay sean well which christian
denomination do you subscribe to that
does not have doctrines written by a
human hand
this this is what always trips me up a
little bit when i hear this sometimes
from christians who are not catholic and
they say oh i don't want all these
doctrines
ev
what what church are you going to where
there are no doctrines
that were physically written by human
beings
now just because doctrine is written by
human beings it doesn't mean that it's
not
that it doesn't come from god
but that's would be my point that would
be my defense of doctrines in the
catholic church
the bible
was physically written by human beings
does that mean it didn't come from god
no
but it was written by human beings it
was in that sense man-made i mean
literally physically made by human
beings
um
and so the
your criticism of catholicism
would seem to you're setting up logic
here that would discard all doctrines
and
all denominations and all of scripture
but you apply it clearly you apply this
logic in a very sort of targeted
somewhat some might even say
hypocritical way
um
b-man
r cole says
pickles
commenting pickles until you acknowledge
my comment and pronounce my username day
107
have you really been leaving the word
pickles under every show for 107 shows
i guess i want to respect your
consistency your follow-through
i hope that was worth it uh yeah all of
that build up you've been waiting for
you know a third of a year
and there you go i have now said pickles
um
techni girl says matt i agree with you
on the porn issue but you're incorrect
when you say that 11 year old girls are
prepubescent many if not most girls
start puberty around age 9 or 10 and by
11 it's in full full swing
i can confirm this as a mother and 11
year old girl anyway keep with the great
work nine is when it begins
my daughter is eight
i'm not ready for that
i'm not
i'm not ready for that don't don't tell
me those things
um and then finally a couple comments
here on the same subject says matt i got
to disagree with you on wishing bad
outcomes for evil people enacting
justice is one thing and should be
established but yet to yearn for ill
will against another isn't christian
certainly not good you either love or
you hate and you can't hold a grudge
against someone you love you can't serve
both satan and god a person who makes
you hate them can control you and i'm
not into this whole new age christianity
where one can do no wrong but to wish
someone face hardship makes you no
better than them i wish for people to
see the glory of god in his love not to
further succumb to evil acts and desires
then jd says it's a good thing to desire
the suffering of others for doing evil
love thy enemy as thyself turn the other
cheek is mad a better authority than
jesus for morality now
um
that's an easy question these are all
pretty easy questions the answer is no
i'm not a better authority than jesus
but also jesus never said anything that
would rule out what i said yesterday
which which is that
we should
want
evil doers
to suffer for their evil deeds we should
want that
and
i know with the kind of milk toast um
christianity that people are so used to
these days the sanitized milk talks
christianity that sort of thing sounds
shocking and kind of uh and and and
really sort of startling
but that's only because you've been
brought up in this military christianity
if i were to make that statement that we
should wish suffering on those who do
evil if i would make that
statement to any christian prior to
about 100 years ago they would have
looked at me like yeah well yeah of
course what do you mean
again that's that's all over the bible
especially in the old testament but but
these these things are not are not
overturned or not reversed or not
negated by the new testament
uh jesus says that himself he's
fulfilling scripture not overturning it
so
look at this one
do you think that evil deeds should be
punished
should a person who commits an evil deed
be punished let's make this real let's
take a let's take a real example it's
unfortunately happened many times you
know in society uh someone who commits
rape
okay a heinous act
do you think that the rapist should be
punished do you want the rapist to be
punished and i know that your answer is
yes
and so what you're saying is you want
the rapist to suffer because that's what
punishment is it is suffering
that's the point of punishment if it's a
punishment where you're not suffering
then it's not a punishment
that is the point of the punishment is
to make someone suffer
to varying degrees
right depending on what the infraction
is if it's a if it's a if it's a pretty
mild infraction but you still feel that
there needs to be a correction
then your
the suffering will be very very minimal
but it's still still still there
even telling someone to pay a fine is
suffering
intentionally but that's what a
punishment is
it is suffering
intentionally oppo imposed on someone
for the sake of justice and for their
own moral betterment
so in fact if you love
the sinner as we're supposed to then
that's even more reason that you would
desire for them to suffer for evil acts
because it is for their own moral
betterment it causes them to confront
what they've done and the severity of it
and that's the only the only hope of
reformation the only hope of of
repentance
is through that is through suffering
so
yes you can you can wish that people who
do evil suffer for those people well not
only was the daily wire the first in the
nation to sue the bible administration
for their unconstitutional mandates but
we're less than 100 000 away from
hitting our goal of 1 million signatures
on our do not comply petition why
because people are realizing that if we
don't actively fight for our freedom the
government will take it reaching one
million signatures will provide a major
boost to our legal challenge uh i don't
know if we would make it to a million
because that's that's that's
pretty impressive and very few petitions
are able to achieve that but we're
getting there we're over 900 000
signatures and if you want to add your
name to the list and you haven't yet go
to dailywire.com do not comply also if
you haven't heard ben shapiro is hosting
a new series exclusively for the daily
wire it's a voyeuristic view of his
conversations with his closest and most
influential friends including jordan
peterson who stopped by on a recent trip
to nashville to be his first guest they
um head to one of ben's favorite local
coffee shops to discuss big ideas and
their private lives as if the cameras
aren't even rolling but they are of
course the premiere episode drops
tonight and will be available only on
dailywire.com so if you're not a member
yet you got to become a member now is
the perfect time to sign up head to
dailywire.com subscribe to to sign up
today uh clips of the show will be
available on youtube as well but if you
want the full show the full experience
go to dailywire.com
subscribe now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know i had planned today to perform
a cancellation revolving around a recent
incident at an airport
and i'm not exactly sure where this
happened but uh i wasn't sure at first
when i saw this but it's a it's a
massive fight broke out between two
groups of people
and you can see some of the footage here
now
the reason why i couldn't say for sure
where it occurred is that there is our
violent skirmishes of this type at
airports every week now so when you
google airport fight as i did the
results won't help you narrow things
down very much but it will provide you
with hours of entertainment uh however
if you're
looking for for distraction
based purely on the exorbitant amount of
time i spend at airports i originally
guessed that this is minneapolis or
chicago
not to stereotype but i also assume that
these are spirit or allegiant passengers
in fact what you're witnessing here is
actually part of the traditional
boarding process for a spirit flight if
you want to board in the first group you
have to defeat the other passengers in
hand-to-hand combat the winner gets to
choose their seat the losers are stuffed
in the cargo hold
but as it happens upon further research
i discovered this flight did indeed
happen this fight did indeed happen a
couple weeks ago in minneapolis though
it appears i unfairly impugned the
indignity of the dignity of spirit and
allegiant
these are it turns out frontier
customers
so i picked the wrong budget airline my
apologies to spirit whose passengers are
much too classy to beat the snot out of
each other in the airport they would at
least wait until they're on the plane to
do that
but the main point here is that
these people are stomping the living
hell out of one another in the middle of
the terminal
right near a tsa checkpoint even using
trash can lids and other objects as
weapons
and notice how nobody is intervening
now consider the fact that i cannot walk
five steps through an airport without
getting yelled at for not wearing a mask
and yet these folks can stage a wwe
match over by gate 12 and at no point
does anyone in airport security even so
much as politely ask them to stop
if i tried to walk through security with
my belt still on let's say
i'd be like tazed and hog-tied and
molested by a man in rubber gloves
but they can commit a series of felony
assaults on one another in an airport
and there are no repercussions at all
there were no arrests after this
incident either by the way if you can
believe it which i'm sure you can no
nobody was arrested for that they were
not stopped from doing it
they weren't even yelled at
and no one was arrested
white privilege takes some very strange
forms you must admit see we're told that
systemic racism is so severe that black
individuals are murdered by police for
the slightest infractions and yet you
watch a video like this or so many
videos like it
and you see violent crimes committed in
the open on camera without police even
showing up to stop it let alone spraying
bullets everywhere as the media claims
would happen
so there appears to be a disconnect
between narrative and reality as always
that anyway was going to be the subject
of the cancellation today and i guess
partially it still is since i've spent
half the segment talking about it but
this is a is a friday and i have to try
to squeeze everything in before the
weekend and so at the last minute
i happen to see a clip of joy reid which
was so egregious
that i changed my mind and i decided
that i needed to cancel her instead
today she's already a member of this
prestigious club of multiply cancelled
people on the matt wall show and now she
can add another one to the tally because
a couple of days ago joy reid took to
her msnbc show that nobody ever sees
except when clips of it are shared on
twitter to make fun of her
and she attacked noted african-american
elon musk for criticizing elizabeth
warren
we don't have to rehash the dispute
between musk and warren the most
relevant point for our purposes today is
that musk called warren
senator karen
okay calling her a karen senator karen
and that provoked this from reed
well elon wasn't happy so he did what he
always did and stopped his little feet
and insulted senator warren calling her
an angry mom and referring to her as
senator karen
so for so many reasons being a
freeloader and a selfish and
disrespectful one and for
misappropriating black vernacular for
misogynistic purposes elon musk is the
absolute worst
meanwhile senator warren has better
things to do than fight with junior
birdman on twitter
now
i want you to think about this because
we have here from joy read multiple
degrees of hypocrisy and anti-white
bigotry layered on top of each other in
a bewildering almost
inception-like way
so as i've argued in the past and reed
herself confirms here really
karen is a racial slur that black people
use against white people the insult
began on social media primarily among
black people to refer to a certain type
of white woman that they don't like
now when members of one race come up
with a derogatory term to describe
members of another race
that is a racial slur by definition
now i know there are a lot of kind of
stupid self-hating white people who who
recoil at this there's even a lot of
white people say it's not a racial slur
don't be ridiculous i mean they
themselves will valiantly defend the
rights of other people to to slur them
but
that's what it is i'm telling you that's
where it comes from
this is one group of people from from
from a certain race came up with a
derogatory term for members of another
race they don't like that is a racial
slur there is no getting around it
again reed acknowledges this
and yet she says that that it's it's
racist for white people to use it
for them to use an anti-white racial
slur because they're appropriating the
term from black culture and black people
she says are the only ones who have the
right to insult white people in that way
suddenly in one amazing death-defying
move of mental gymnastics reed has made
black people into the victims of a
racial slur used by black people against
white people
now compare this of course with other
slurs used against other groups of
people which were then reclaimed by the
targeted group so that now they are the
only ones who are allowed to say them
think about that
but white people are not welcome to do
the same thing with slurs that target
them
shut up whitey and let us insult you joy
reid says
this is the kind of thing that makes
anti-white racism not only
um
the the only sort of racism that exists
in the country
i mean it's it's not it's rather not the
only sort of racism that exists in the
country of course there are always going
to be racist people of all races
directing their ire out to other groups
okay so that exists across the board
there are white races there are black
races that are asian races and so on but
anti-white racism is the most dangerous
form of racial bigotry in the country
today by far because it's the only form
that is socially acceptable
joy reid can sit in front of a camera on
national television and openly defend an
anti-white racial slur claim it as her
own as part of her culture
and there are no penalties of any kind
it's hardly even noticed
joy reed is herself a raging drooling
white hating bigot and she makes no
effort whatsoever to hide it
she doesn't need to there are no
professional or social consequences for
her for her form of racism
which is what makes it so uniquely
dangerous
and will lead and is leading to very
dark places
and that's why she today
is finally canceled
and also minneapolis airport security
are cancelled as well for the record
and we'll leave it there for today and
the week have a great weekend talk to
you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin